- These days, I have noticed
you don't like wearing shirts.
Now, I gotta be real with you.
If I looked like you, I don't
think I'd wear a shirt either.
- [Kelly] Look at him
coming out of that water!
Coming out of that water like a beast!
- I'm from Miami.
We don't wear shirts in Miami.
We call it no-shirt-shorty.
No-shirt-shorty.
It's like, what you wearing?
- In Texas we have signs,
you can't even get in
without like shirt and shoes.
It's like, they don't even let you in.
We wanna go in like that, like
after the Lakers (mumbles).
So what do you do to treat yourself?
You work out, you're such a beast.
You work out all the time.
What do you do to treat yourself?
- Food wise?
- Or anything!
Yeah, food wise, I mean mine's cake.
- Yeah, I love cake.
- I love chocolate cake.
- Oh my goodness, chocolate
cake is unbelievable.
You put a little ice cream
with that, it's amazing.
- Yes!
- I also love, you know
after a good work out,
I love having vodka and muscle milk,
like vodka and protein,
vodka and muscle milk.
- Wait, you mix vodka
with a protein shake?
- Ya, so it's basically...
- It's like uppers and downers.
- You're getting fit
while you're getting lit!
You know what I'm saying?
(joyful laughing)